jacky ickx bonsoir vous connaissez tous
le monde et même les mots pianiste
églantine eméyé animatrice de télévision
mimie mathy comédienne alain lipietz
futur président de la république et
thomas dutronc qui a exactement la même
désinvolture que son père ce qui fait
très plaisir à voir moi j'adore
maintenant parce que x
ça me fait penser quand j'étais petit on
lisait les bandes dessinées non non
c'est parce que vous croyez
non c'est quand j'étais petit avait des
bandes dessinées que le pilote son
visage comme ça c'était l'époque de
michel vaillant les défunts de gratton
et moi pour moi jacky ickx et c'est tout
ce à quoi s'est lié à tout ça je serais
heureux de vous recevoir
c'est un pilote de légende on sait quand
ni combien de compris j'ai gagné oui
grand pays et participer à combien 116
un moment comme une victoire 6 6
ouais vous appeler monsieur le mans nous
avait été nommé pilote des 24 heures du
mans pour xxème siècle tamesna remet ça
comme titre vous appeler aux sirènes
master vous étiez fort sous la pluie
comme schumacher un très fort sous la
pluie c'est quoi le secret pour conduire
sous la pluie il ya pas mort il n'y a
pas beaucoup déçu glaçant en formule 1
c'est quoi elle pas qu'il faut beaucoup
de sensibilité j'ai fait beaucoup de
motos avant de faire et la voiture ça
m'a beaucoup aidé aujourd'hui j'ai
toujours sur 4 ou vous organisez des
rallyes notamment le rallye d'égypte et
nous organiser aussi des courses vous
êtes directeur de course du grand prix
de monaco
dernièrement directeur de l'épreuve des
69e 24 heures du mans les 16 et 17 juin
dernier et votre fille court et oui
ganina vous connaissez beaucoup de
choses de moi on va voir vanina une de
vos filiales et dans l'écurie de paul
belmondo sur chrysler viper
elle a 26 ans c'était sa première
participation j'ai été content de ses
performances
j'aurais été content s'il avait été à
l'arrivée oui mais c'est vrai que c'est
très émotionnel a abandonné pendant la
nuit ça
elle a abandonné pendant la nuit sur
cette île sortie de route mais c'est
vrai que on vit des choses différemment
quand on a quelqu'un qui fait
un sport à risque et qui est parfois
partie de sa famille moi je me souviens
en tous les cas ma mère en son temps il
ya 30 ans eh bien elle avait des
week-ends très très difficile et je le
comprends mieux aujourd'hui
elle vous avez vu courir au mans votre
fils parce que les sept ans 81 2 quand
vous avez gagné pour l'un pour la
dernière fois en plus du mont à la filda
car elle a fait un diana police
elle fait beaucoup de compétition
automobile quand même
elle va se lancer maintenant on va faire
ça on va finir par croire qu'il ya des
gènes pourraient être dans la course
automobile m'intrigue a salué venu tard
elle faisait des études de biologie
université en biologie a terminé sa
biologie et quand elle l'a terminée elle
a décidé de faire la course automobile
mais franchement j'étais pas au courant
parce que c'est plutôt une vocation
tardive mais vous aussi c'est pas vu
tout de suite on va en parler
alors jacques xgp en 1945 à ixelles en
belgique votre père était journaliste
automobile avait été auparavant un très
célèbre rallye man votre frère aussi
était dans la compétition automobile
dont vous aviez un environnement très
mécanique mais vous savez vous approchez
pas à ça vous dit quand j'étais gosse je
détestais l'automobile vous trouviez les
courses terriblement ennuyeuse quand on
sait ce que vous êtes devenu et un jour
j'ai demandé à votre père de plus vous
emmener aux courses automobiles à
l'école n'était pas meilleur mauvais
élèves
même pas un bon sportif disait vos
professeurs et l'âge de 16 ans c'est
vrai tout ça est l âge de 16 ans pour
meubler vos dimanches vous mettez à la
moto mais comme ça non juste pour vous
occuper sans passion véritable oui tout
ça c'est vrai devrait faire attention
parce que j'ai des enfants petits qui
vont peut-être me regarder et en fait
j'étais premier à l'école ah bon oui
d'accord définitivement leur 10e chez
leurs élèves mais plus on pourrait alors
non tout est vrai ouais et alors bon
vous faites de la moto vraiment beaucoup
occupé le dimanche après midi 12 ans
merdier et puis vous faites vos
premières courses et l'importateur de
zoom d'ap vous confie une moto
officielle
et puis ensuite l'importateur de suzuki-
vous confie une moto et là vous
commencez à vous découvrir une âme de
pilotes m'ont peut pas dire que c'est
venu très naturellement tout ça en tous
les cas la tradition familiale n'a pas
influé sur vous outre mesure parce que
vous devez commencer par refuser ça au
départ
peut-être même que le fait de faire de
la moto s'est déjà il possède une autre
façon de refuser l'automobile je vais
essayer de résumer ça entraînements
c'est vrai que
ma scolarité n'a pas été formidable et
c'est vrai que j'ai entendu dire très
très souvent que je ne serais je ne
serai pas seulement mauvais à tout mais
bon à rien alors
alors c'est vrai que j'aurais aimé sans
doute être j'adorais la nature
j'adorerais jolivet très seul très
solitaire j'adorais la nature je pensais
être peut-être garde-chasse peut-être
jardinier chez que ça prête à sourire
j'aimais pas les courses tout simplement
pas lui ça lui plaît beaucoup c'est à
dire les trouver sa place
j'ai trouvé ça monstrueusement ennuyeux
les courses automobiles
mais c'est vrai qu'à travers la moto
j'ai découvert que finalement je pouvais
aussi gagner ouais ça vous a plu et le
goût de gagner c'est quand même bien
alors on continue notre histoire donc on
peut à tout départ n'est pas l'intention
de devenir un pro mais finalement vous
êtes pris dans cette espèce de
d'engrenages il prenait goût et là vous
apprenez vraiment à conduire en fait au
service militaire lorsqu'il faut savoir
c'est que jacky qui se retrouvent au
service militaire dans les blindés et y
conduit des amics 15 tonnes 1 c'est
lourd conduire 1 avec 12 en à bord et
vous avez appris le dérapage contrôlé
c'est vrai en conduisant des chars
d'assaut
je vous dit que cantona quand on arrive
à faire un dérapage contrôlé avec un
char d'assaut affronter des merveilles
que n'importe quelle caisse c'est vrai
les à mx qui est un chat france est elle
un char chenille est un jeu ni
métalliques sont sans les gommes donc on
pouvait faire de très très beaux tête à
queue et j'arrivais à me ranger dans les
parkings avant le décollage
voilà en marche arrière en faisant de
très beaux tête à queue mais j'ignorais
encore à ce moment là que j'allais faire
l'automobile après le service doit vous
revenez vous avez quoi 21 ans 66 et la
boue rencontre et ken tyrrell qu'ils
installent d'abord en formule 3 et en
formule 2 qui s'était ken tyrrell à
l'époque
ken tyrrell elle est là aussi c'est un
no ken tyrrell est l'homme qui a
fait rouler françois cevert vinci ward
qui a qui a fait rouler le premier les
matra laventure matras et ken tyrrell
c'est le renouveau de la france dans le
sport automobile tant au niveau
industriel qu'au niveau des pilotes
puisque dans toute cette période qui va
suivre
on va trouver sept huit pilotes français
tous deux très très grande qualité et
tout ce qu'ils auront connu finalement
des succès peut-être différent mais tous
de très très haut niveau et je pense à
françois sévère parce que c'est
peut-être ça c'est vraiment les débuts
de matra alors lui il y avait que c'est
plein de bagnols à cannes ou turrel mais
je finis par il attendait que vous avez
fini votre ex terrains néerlandais il
faut commencer par les patients oui il
faut beaucoup de courage fou quand on
casse les voitures des autres il faut
beaucoup de courage pour renouveler sa
confiance serait alors en 66 si vos
premiers 24 heures du mans un an 67
c'est vos grands débuts vous gagnez les
1000 km de spa sous la pluie c'est la
gauche obtenez ce surnom de reine
masters angel leur building et vous
passez chez ferrari alors pourquoi ce
qu'elle tire à la qui vous deviez tout
pourquoi un jour vous l'abandonnez pour
passer chez le commande de thorey ça a
été un choix cornélien parce que c'est
vrai que quand quelqu'un vous a choisi
et vous à quelque part créé fait
connaître le sommet on est extrêmement
redevable de plein de choses et c'est
aussi évident que si j'avais pu
continuer avec lui j'aurais continué
avec moi mais les destiner varient à
certains moments il faut faire des choix
le choix fait rare est aussi un très bon
valable trois ans dont kenza farah et
flèches sur vous et 23 ans
vous rentrez dans la scuderia objecte le
plus jeune pilote qui ait jamais eu à la
scuderia et en 1968
vous gagnez votre premier grand prix à
rouen toujours sous la main
cinquante mille spectateurs 17 voitures
au départ le grand prix de france courue
sur le circuit de rouen les essarts
s'annoncer comme une grande réussite
il ya bien longtemps que l'on avait vu
une voiture rouge du commendatore
ferrari remporté une victoire et à rouen
sa numéro 26 piloté par le benjamin de
la course le belge jacky ickx gags
dangereuses ou non utile ou non la
course des 24 heures du mans reste le
spectacle de sportif le plus prisé du
monde
quatre cent mille spectateurs cette
année
à présent la ford gt40 de jacky ickx et
oliver est en troisième position
elle grignote les porsche elle va les
avoir à l'usure et sera peu avant 14
heures
l'extraordinaire ce prix x herman dont
jacky ickx se sentira vainqueur faisant
tourner c'est bien leur tour les têtes
des spectateurs
panis catastrophe voyage au bout de
l'enfer ces mots sortir en plus tard de
la bouche des meilleurs concurrents
jacky ickx lui même ne sera pas épargnée
et s'égarera sur la piste avant de
retrouver presque par hasard
l'arbre du ténéré c'est ce qui s'est
passé j'ai qui on a cassé le bon enfant
avant à 90 km à 6,6
soixante voitures soit le tiers
seulement des engagés finir le rallye
parcours sans faute pour jacky ickx et
claude brasseur
victorieux avec une heure d'avancé sur
trossat briavoine de ce paris dakar de
la revente
jacky ickx alors on a vu on a vu deux
choses intéressantes alarmantes au sujet
on a vu d'abord ce qu'on appelait le
départ le mans c'est à dire que les
pilotes traversé la piste à pied pour
aller se mettre dans la voiture et vous
vous trouviez ça dangereux et une année
je suis en quelle année c'était vous
avez refusé de le faire vous êtes allé
très doucement comme ça pour montrer que
j'étais contre cette idée de traverser
la piste pour les enfants dans la
voiture il a aidé à presse été supprimés
oui c'est exact mais à travers ses
images dans le fond je me rends compte
que j'ai fait beaucoup de choses
et dans le fond les palmarès
c'est une chose sur laquelle j'aime
beaucoup revenir c'est l'occasion pour
moi de le dire on se rend compte que les
palmarès à ce compte ça se construit
vraiment sur la passion des autres c'est
à dire que c'est vrai que j'ai un beau
palmarès mais en vieillissant ou en
étant un peu moins jeunes on se rend
compte combien on dépend de l'anonymat
et de la passion partagée l'écurie parce
que quand on parle de tout ça en fait
j'ai dit je n'ai jamais été seule un
jour eu plein d'intervenants je suis
comme la télé la survie on croit que les
malheurs qui veut dire bon c'est facile
de ce vrai que c'est facile de lire
c'est un travail d'équipé
mais c'est vraiment une réelle et je
veux dire la passion c'est formidable et
c'est vrai que c'est grâce à ça que des
gens comme moi ou d'autres où les
pilotes modèle gagne c'est grâce à tous
ces gens qui à ces travailleurs de
l'ombre et ça je pense que très
important de le dire c'est pas une
formule comme ça banal et elle est une
réalité dans le succès d'une vie ou dans
la réussite lundi alors on a vu aussi
effectivement le dakar sur le tas qu'à
soi quand on donne une nouvelle
dimension à votre vie parce que il y
avait toujours la course évidemment est
le plaisir que vous y preniez niveau sil
aventure que d'un seul coup ça a ajouté
une dimension extraordinaire à tout ça
non c'est un c'est à dire que c'est
difficile d'expliquer c'est difficile
d'expliquer quand vous courrez pendant
35 ans et que tout vous réussit très
bien avec beaucoup de beaucoup de chance
c'est difficile d'expliquer alors que
dans le fond on connaît plus la perle la
partie
j'allais dire télévisé où la partie
connue ou professionnel c'est très
difficile d'expliquer que probablement
mes plus belles années en tous les cas
ce sont les années thierry sabine zabrze
la paix thierry sabine parce que entre
les quinze qui me concerne c'est un
homme qui a changé ma vie en faisant
cette course du paris dakar
j'ai découvert qu'il y avait d'autres
choses
il veut vraiment d'autre chose que de
sport le sport c'est formidable le dakar
c'est des formidables mais à côté de ça
il y avait l'afrique que je ne
connaissais pas il y avait des airs que
je ne connaissais pas il y avait là
dureté pas du désert en particulier mais
la dureté de l'afrique
ça m'a fait prendre franchement une
dimension intellectuelle d'abord
différentes
et puis ça m'a remis ça m'a bien remis
les choses en perspective
oui en place parce que vraiment quand on
refuse je vais penser aux états unis
d'un seul côté star du piano puis elle
s'est retrouvée aux états unis comme ça
excellent ou non mais remet les choses
voilà quand on revient de là on prend sa
place exacte peu importe ce que vous
avez fait le passé et finalement on n'a
pas beaucoup d'importance le futur a
probablement beaucoup plus d'intérêt
mais surtout vous prenez une taille
humaine et puis ça vous apprend à mettre
un bémol à vos égaux on est mieux
alors il ya évidemment il ya beaucoup de
pilotes qui sont qui sont célèbres mais
je peux vous une image comme ça de
gentleman driver et c'est vrai qu'en 68
ya une anecdote qui est qui est tout à
fait bouleversante et 23 ans
vous venez de gagner votre premier grand
prix de formule 1 rouen et dans ce grand
prix jo schlesser a trouvé la mort et
vous allez chercher votre bouquet
puisque c'est le bouquet de la
récompense ou faites votre tour et vous
vous arrêtez votre voix vous arrêtez
votre voiture à l'endroit où je les sers
a trouvé la mort et vous déposez le
bouquet convient de vous remettre à moi
ça me semble à moi ça me semble normal
vrai c'est pour ça va mal parce que
c'est vrai qu'à conserver l'on parle
toujours des joies mais aussi des
moments de grande tristesse et de
grandes
de très grande dureté et c'est vrai que
le sport automobile 10 à 30 ans c'est un
sport à haut risque et beaucoup
d'accidents oui j'ose les terres étaient
français c'était la course de sa vie est
aussi bon le jour d'une très très grande
tragédie alors finalement la victoire
n'avait pas beaucoup d'importance parce
que il y avait une grande tristesse qui
régna rouen à midi là vous ai pas
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui les courses
automobiles de formule 1 sont devenues
un peu moins un gentleman quoique c'est
un peu plus se baser sur le sur la
victoire pure sur l'argent il ya plus
cotés club racing club qui avait à
l'époque je pense que je ne sais pas je
pense pas qu'il faille faire des
comparaisons très sincèrement j'ai vécu
une autre époque
bon c'était l'argent avait pas beaucoup
d'importance on conduisait c'était
dangereux
ça s'apparente est probablement plus un
acte de chevalerie oui c'est ça que je
voulais dire certainement inconscient
parce que personne ne pensait aux
risques encourus la course moderne c'est
c'est un autre spectacle du jeu vidéo
aujourd'hui non mais franchement c'est
très très difficile
c'est très très très très difficile ce
qu'ils font ce métier là c'est ses 22
élu de la formule 1 ce sont tous des
gens exceptionnels
moi j'ai beaucoup de respect pour eux et
franchement dans certaines dans certains
cas je me demande même si j'aurais
jamais pu conduire ce genre de gauche
donc je suis bien et cheminer dans la
bonne époque je ne les envie pas je
trouve ce mérite je trouve qu'ils
méritent ce qu'ils méritent en tous les
cas le succès qu'il connaît c'est un
sport très